so here is the cathedral
the name of which i can't remember but
it's a reminder that the french were
here and that maybe i think maybe 15 of
the population
here
is christian catholic i think there's
some protestants as well
now
uh one thing that i
want to remind people is we want to have
a meet up first of all look at my nice
vietnamese shirt this is uh
seeing these t-shirts around so i bought
one
but
we're going to spend another three days
here and then we're off to seoul
and so those who are interested in
having a meet-up on the 20th
um
please indicate you're you know that you
want to come on the 20th and probably
the easiest thing to would be to meet
at the exit i think it's the hui
exit of the
subway and exit number one and then
there's so many little restaurants
around there we can find a place to go
and eat so let's aim for seven o'clock
on the 20th
exit number one and i'll put the name of
the uh subway stop in the description
and so those have we had a very nice
meet up here in uh
in hanoi and i'm gonna be putting
together some pictures and videos of the
videos that i've been taking but let's
get those who want to meet in seoul
please let me know
all right
and i'll be putting up some videos of
our touring around here in vietnam